[Music]
check it out we'll get straight to it
a walmart worker restrained a deer in a
wisconsin store
how big is this [ __ ] deer they
wrestled how do you restrain
it it was just a funny video i looked it
up i laughed i wanted to share it it's
gotta be a baby deer dude big deer's
oh my god that's a big deal i love these
videos that's technique
oh dude it's damn oh wow wow
the confidence you need to restrain a
deer yo
we kind of missed the good part of the
video though i know
like how they took them down yeah that
is holding an lcd tv
the deer try to run away and walk it
towards the exit yeah
it is crazy that deer just came in the
store like that have you seen the video
of like a hair salon
and a deer runs through the window jumps
over a lady sitting on the couch and
just runs the [ __ ] out
and they're all freaking out she's
cutting hair and then just a deer
smashes through the window and just runs
out the back is it one of those things
where like nobody actually reacts
yeah kind of well they all started
running as soon as the glass shatters i
saw this one where it's a while
before a wild boar runs down the hill
here's a store
and it goes boom and the glass breaks
and i guess it startles the boar but it
still wants to go through so it goes
boom boom boom boom and just shatters
all the glass in the room
oh [ __ ] that's the tusks what a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why there's a lot of videos like
that where like
uh bulls run into shops and like yeah i
love those
they're pretty fun i have to say i love
the bull run videos where a bunch of
white dudes are getting [ __ ] taken
out
it's like what do you think was gonna
happen bro yeah he's like he's like i'm
drinking margaritas
the drink of the land
[Laughter]
i'm gonna [ __ ] run with the balls and
get [ __ ] wiped out every time it's
the best yo we know someone that
did that really did he have a lay on too
no i know anthony anthony did
and he's wrong was that you yeah why
didn't you chime in earlier
because i told that story here because
he's waiting for us to be stupid first
oh gosh you got you
yeah well i don't tell i told you before
on jk news i don't think i was here did
did you
i mean you obviously made it okay but
did you get hurt no nice
because he strategizes where to go right
big strategy
but not many people get hurt
percentage-wise it's like one another
yeah yeah not a lot of people get hurt
you should check out lively
i've seen some different things yeah
it's like the compilation of the fails
of the bull run
yeah people don't always get hurt from
the bulls
they'll get hurt themselves right
literally there's a pamphlet that gets
passed around that talks about things
like be careful you might die and it's
like
it's so nonchalant that it's scary but
then it talks about how like if you like
fall
or whatever like stay down and the most
uh important animal to fear here is
humans
because they'll travel over each other
because like even if you for example
like bulls around
by your side or down the center lane
right if you try to go to the side and
you're trying to escape
there's people drunk on the outside that
push you back
and if you're holding a margarita that
thing's going right on you
and your shirt's ruined that's all over
that's it and you look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you gotta down it before
dude i'm out bro don't get a glass get
the [ __ ] container
yeah dude how many people partake in
each bull run
and there's no sign releases right it's
just like hey yeah there's no sign
release uh
if you if you go in there you're that's
your signed release especially if you're
like adorned in like their cultural
clothes yarn all white with the red sash
or like holding a newspaper and stuff
like you're you're [ __ ] there for a
reason that newspapers just slap them in
the head right slap in the butt
or slap him in general has anyone ever
dressed like a bull for multiples
so you blend in so that bulls don't
think you got to go with a friend so
you could be the front in the back you
know no one's ever done that i think
bull doesn't know that you're they're
like oh that's another boy
i'm not sure if that's how it works
that's [ __ ] you oh
no oh no oh [ __ ] what did we do with the
female costume it was cheaper
[Laughter]
oh boy dude you come in as a cow
back to back to the deer um
if if a [ __ ] animal jumps into
barbell brigade or something like that
you think you're gonna be able to tackle
it
or what would you do you just let it
like do its damage
what kind of animal is it a [ __ ] a
deer say a deer
i just leave it alone it's harmless just
wait till it goes out we have brothers
probably
not harmless really they're gonna
destroy all the stuff
maybe maybe harmless to like fellow
humans but like it's definitely gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
to what metal plates it's gonna might
kick your mirrors
you know it might like run through like
the window in your office it's gonna
bend some bars yo
yeah maybe i'll get my shirt and go shoe
go away
i [ __ ] with a deer not a buck what
especially if they have horns
oh yeah yeah no bucks and they're bigger
too deers run into everything
like a lot of people have stories about
how they [ __ ] up their rearview mirrors
in their car they just run in their cars
all the time because they're [ __ ]
[ __ ]
probably just gonna leave a b though
right like it's like you're gonna [ __ ]
up
it's like a i don't know just whatever
happens happens
i wouldn't think to grab when i watched
that video all i could think about was
like what if that deer has ticks
that's all i'm thinking about kicks was
the first thing i went through that's
the first thing i thought about okay
how sick would it be if during the
pre-game the milwaukee or i'm sorry the
the phoenix suns
bring out a [ __ ] buck's head and just
parade it around
and it's all bloody and [ __ ] wow like
fresh meat not a good dog getting their
[ __ ] head yeah
talk about some soccer teams do that
[ __ ] all the time
what yeah that's a thing with animal
abuse with the mascot
yeah with a mascot that's actually
animal abuse movies
when like there's like the two rival
high schools i didn't know that it was a
real thing
i think he's referencing movies you know
no but like come on europe
yeah in europe because like crazy
because they take soccer i mean sorry
football they take that [ __ ] very
seriously
well you mean maybe like the bar clubs
not necessarily like the teams right
i don't i don't know what scene dude i
remember reading a story
what are you see that where they
actually decapitated like a goat's head
or some [ __ ] or i didn't even know they
had
mascots i thought they were just
countries yeah i don't know like
england versus spain like yeah what's
what's manchester united what is that
it's a guy [ __ ] drunken place
that's the mascot i think it represents
a family crest
but what is it is it a place is it like
the los angeles lakers manchester united
i think manchester is a city
the city and then united is so it's city
they're feeling about the city
yeah yeah everybody together so it's a
city team unity
like l.a lakers what about barse lonna
barcelona um
bar say i'm not sure what's alona fc
fc barcelona fc is like we don't know
anything about soccer
don't we have one in la at the home
galaxy dude
there's another team though i thought
that name is whack the galaxy
what kind of mascot is that by the way
space a star 12 planets
do you have that guy come out does he
what does he do does he dance what does
he do
he should dance you should he might as
well he should be jabba walkies
he should be jailbroken that's the
universe personified
the jab blockies because they do that
black and white thing where they pop up
with their faces and they're everywhere
oh i see i see i see they look like the
milky way or something you know
i don't know how they dance in that i'm
like bro you guys are good
like you can't just be [ __ ] tripping
and falling if they were in that [ __ ]
i know that for a fact they'd be
tripping oh [ __ ] yeah dude
with that for a second we tripped on the
shoelaces dude
is it really your dance group that's the
dance crew yeah ken jesus yeah yeah the
guys who'd be tripping and falling
that's his dance moves
would you treat us to a little
performance uh if you treat us to a
little performance in your career i did
i showed you guys how to have an
internal
um hand job did she give us a free
seminar do we know how to make nipples
come on
he's a world famous dancer in case you
don't know forget it world famous like
he's really good
it's you know you really got to lower
your expectations around these guys
this is why it's a just kidding show you
know no he's well he's world class
for a second there i thought we had a
host of jk news
bart pass the wave
[Music]
that's all i got that's all i got so
bring it back to the real topic
we're talking about deers here guys i
was still pretty good we'll show you
some videos later
yeah yeah that should be the next video
as we show you
all his videos with him dancing and then
you react to it it's weird to like do a
demonstration with no music when dance
is like based off of musical feelings
you could play something right now
hey tell a joke comedy guy yeah thank
you hey you got a [ __ ] joke you funny
think you're funny
say something funny hey you're not very
[ __ ] funny man get out of the street
then
you just did it but you just did it you
made a joke about it and it was funny
lebron james yeah dude lebron james
lebron it's not
easy it's not easy do you have a
favorite move that
is you like this going to get them no no
everyone's got something no i always try
to practice like the
the look i'm talking about when you're
like
you look one way and then you like try
to cross the side before you go into the
other way [ __ ] that's a mini wave yeah
that's amazing but then or like the dick
someone you're like this one you're like
this
oh i feel like that's like very easy to
sit down and stay under
well he's also practiced it a lot yeah
he's really good no with the tongue with
the tongue doesn't make sense if the
dick goes in here it shouldn't
be here already it doesn't work to go
through like the front of your chin
here dick comes from the back of your
throat and you have to like perceive it
pushing
from like a frontal area my bad i
thought i didn't think i was upside down
okay
my bad i didn't think i was upside down
i wasn't you're so good that you
practice
the face dancing well everything he's a
true
he's a true master this one can move his
body in any way he wants to i know but
like he's
at home practicing how his eyes are
dancing in coordination the rest of his
body
this cat is hosting jknews all day today
he's leaving here he's going to go
dance from eight to one in the morning
you guys are making it sound like i'm a
pro that's a five hour
pro you are the most pro out of but if
we put you in a jabberwocky costume
you're [ __ ] tripping and falling all
over the ground
not good enough this one's a jabberwocky
with a hard r
he's not cool he said that it's all good
yeah jabberwocky hey you should see me
check my hat
in the rain pal
let's go watch the jabber walk yeah damn
right nobody sees down playing himself
his
crew is very so big that they can make
instant noodles
completely offset jabberwockies are here
you guys need to stop with this right
now jabberwockies don't have instant
noodles
you know why because they don't need
them that's true sure they're gonna do
hacky [ __ ] like be a galaxy you know you
know what i mean like
they're not like hinges never even had
to think of it they have a gift shop at
the luxor
nobody's in there either is that true
yes all of it's true
there's a gift shop for your dance group
no job wise
jabbawockeez is the lower version of the
hinges his crew is the kenja's
jabberwocky's down here kendra's up
nick's the only one doesn't know what
he's talking about
it's true i've watched a lot of their
videos after i started you know hanging
out with anthony and i was like wow
they're
very [ __ ] good yeah everyone has
better things outside of jk and they
come here
because they like us that's love this is
the best place in the world frankly the
best room in the world
it's awesome now you know they're
[ __ ] around